BUT NOT IN EASIER TO BE A
RECEIVER. NO. KENYALA DAY NOT
A WHOLE LOT OF ACTION. YEAH
EXPECTED TO VISIT. THE GIANTS
HAS AN OFFER FROM THE BENGALS.
WELL, IT MUST NOT BE A GREAT
OFFER. HE WOULD HAVE TAKEN
IT. YOU KNOW, THIS IS A GUY
WHO I THINK HAD
HAD DESIGNS ON 20 MILLION A
YEAR, MAYBE MORE. THIS ISN'T
THE YEAR NUMBER ONE FOR CAP
REASONS TO GET IT NUMBER TWO
WITH ALL THESE GREAT YOUNG
RECEIVERS. HOW CAN YOU
JUSTIFY HOW CAN YOU JUSTIFY
PUTTING THAT MUCH MONEY IN A
GUY WHO DIDN'T PLAY MUCH AT
ALL LAST YEAR RIGHT JUST
DRAFT A RECEIVER AND CHANCES
BETTER THAN 50/50 THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO GET A GUY THAT CAN
COME IN AND PLAY. YEAH. NO
MIKE. I MEAN, I THINK YOU'RE
RIGHT THERE LIKE A WHEN YOU
JUST EVALUATE THE SITUATION
AND YOU SAID THIS LAST WEEK,
YOU KNOW THE SALARY CAP
FORGET THAT IT'S
LOWER THAN IT WAS LAST YEAR.
IT'S ABOUT WHAT TEAMS
EXPECTED IT TO BE IN THIS
YEAR. AND WHAT WAS THE NUMBER
YOU THREW OUT THERE THAT IT
REALLY IS 2008. YAHWEH TRIES.
IT'S LIKE SO 25 MILLION
DOLLARS LESS THAN WHERE TEAMS
EXPECTED TO BE IN 2010. I
THINK THAT'S WHY YOU SEE, YOU
KNOW, GOD TODAY STILL OUT
THERE JUJU SOMETHING TO
SHUSTER BECAUSE THEY'RE GOING
BY THE OLD MARKET GOING WAIT,
WAIT THESE GUYS SIGNED FOR
THIS LAST YEAR IN THE
OFFSEASON. I'M THE SAME TYPE
OF PLAYER OR BETTER SHOULDN'T
I GET A LITTLE BIT MORE
FIVE AS FAR AS THE SALARY
CAPS CONCERNED AND THEN THE
OTHER MIGHT BE YOUR SPOT ON
THE OTHER ASPECT IS THAT YOU
KNOW, WE'RE STARTING TO SEE
THE DRAFT. IT RECEIVERS ARE
THEY'RE GROWING ON TREES
RIGHT NOW. I MEAN, WE SAW A
LOT OF TALENTED SECOND AND
THIRD ROUND GUYS CONTRIBUTE
TO THEIR FOOTBALL TEAMS LAST
YEAR. I MEAN JUST THINK OF
CHASE CLAYPOOL AND DK MEDCALF
THE LAST TWO YEARS THE BEST
TO YOUNG RECEIVERS OF THE
GAME. THERE WERE DRAFTED LATE
IN THE SECOND ROUND. SO, YOU
AND YOU KNOW, I'VE EVALUATED
THE RECEIVERS. I PROBABLY
WATCHED SOMEWHERE BETWEEN 20
AND 25 OF THEM RIGHT NOW. YOU
KNOW, THERE'S THERE'S SIX
SEVEN GUYS THAT ARE FIRST
ROUND TYPE OF TALENTS RIGHT
THERE. SO THAT HURTS THE
MARKET AS WELL AND WE'LL SEE
GOD THEY WOULD BE A GREAT
ADDITION TO THAT TEAM TO GO
WITH SLAYTON INGRAM AND SE
KWANG BERKELEY. WOW, YOU'RE
PUTTING DANIEL JONES IN A
POSITION TO SUCCEED WITH THAT.
I WOULD BE EXCITED AS A
GIANT SEND TO HAVE GOT LE
THERE, BUT IT'S GOT TO BE THE
RIGHT PRICE. YEAH WHEN I'M
NOT DEALING WITH A JETS FAN
IN MY EAR PRODUCING THE SHOW.
I'M DEALING WITH A GIANTS FAN
IN MY EAR PRODUCING TEABAG -
WANTS TO KNOW IF KENNY GALA
DAY IS A MUST SIGN FOR THE
GIANTS IN EUROPEAN. I DON'T
KNOW IF HE'S A MUST SIGN. I
DON'T LOOK AT IT AND GO. OH
MAN, LIKE GOSH IF THEY DON'T
GET HIM, THEY NEED ANOTHER
PRESENCE AND THE WIDE
RECEIVER ROOM. THEY DO I WILL
SAY THAT I'M NOT SAYING
THAT'S KENNY GALA DAY. I LIKE
KENNY GALA DAY BECAUSE HE'S
BIG PLAYS AND YET HE'S
LUNCH PAIL.
AGAI TO WILL CATCH A SLANT
OVER THE MIDDLE AND BREAK A
TACKLE AND GET 15 MORE YARDS,
BUT HE ALSO WILL RUN BY OR
CATCH A 50-50 BALL 55 YARDS
DOWN THE FIELD AND MAKE A
HIGHLIGHT PLAY TOO. THAT'S
WHERE HE'S AWESOME. HE'S A
LITTLE BIT OF A DIFFERENCE
MAKER THAT WAY AND HE'S GOT
YOU KNOW, ALL ASPECTS OF THE
GAME ARE REALLY GOOD. IT'S
HARD TO FIND A WEAKNESS. THE
BIG WEAKNESS IS LIKE WHAT YOU
TALKED ABOUT, YOU KNOW, IT'S
A YEAR WHERE MONEY'S SHORT
AND YOU KNOW RECEIVERS
THERE'S A LOT OF THEM ALSO
AND THEN HE PLAYED SIX GAMES
THAT'S GOING TO SCARE THE
BUT I MEAN, IT'S YES, HE'S A
RECEIVER BE
FINICKY ATHLETES AT TIMES
TOO. BUT I DO THINK THE
GIANTS NEED ANOTHER, YOU KNOW
LEGIT PRESENCE OVER THERE,
WHETHER THAT'S SOMEBODY ELSE
IN FREE AGENCY OR THE DRAFT.
THEY GOT TO GET THAT DONE.